una nueva tragedia migratoria en aguas
del Mediterráneo
frente a las costas de Siria una
embarcación con decenas de libaneses y
sirio sabordo náufragó
había entre 140 150 migrantes en el
barco nos habría decir con exactitud
Cuánto se quedaron en el interior y
cuántos lograron saltar
el barco zarpó el 20 de septiembre desde
el puerto libanés del distrito de minieg
según informó el ministro de transporte
del Líbano su destino Europa chipre e
Italia los puntos más cercanos pero a la
altura de la ciudad sería de tartus
ocurrió el naufragio las causas del
hundimiento Aún se desconocen las
operaciones de rescate continúan la
cifra de víctimas mortales ha ido
aumentando de manera drástica sin
embargo también hay sobrevivientes están
siendo atendidos en hospitales sirios
este naufragio se convierte en uno de
los más trágicos en la historia
migratoria de sirios y libaneses hacia
Europa superando lo ocurrido de abril de
este año que causó la muerte de más de
30 migrantes cada vez son más Los
libaneses que buscan salir de su país
debido a la grave crisis económica
traducida en desplome de la lira
libanesa y altas tasas de inflación
quienes se quedan deben soportar el
crecimiento del costo de vida según
Naciones Unidas alrededor del 80% de la
población libanesa vive en condiciones
de pobreza